Nintendo's always giving people choices
when it comes to handhelds so it comes
as no surprise to see new 3ds models on
the horizon yet the introduction of
Nintendo's new 3ds feels different it's
not just about size or value they're
practically the same size is the
original 30s in 3dsxl but they're
technically superior in every way in a
market where that's the case maybe the
better question is where do the new 3ds
systems leave the old models the answer
in their dust
let's start from the top for the first
time since I started using a 3ds four
years ago I feel not just comfortable
but excited when using the system's 3d
feature by installing a second camera
above the new 3ds XL top screen Nintendo
made it possible for the system to
detect your relative position and adjust
the 3d effect accordingly it's such a
drastic improvement over previous models
that once you see in action it's
impossible to go back to the 3d of old
there are two new buttons ZL and Zr
stuffed between the standard l and r
shoulder buttons on the new 3ds XL and
antennas also crammed a small stiff
analog nub between the face buttons and
the bottom screen though it looks like
it might be uncomfortable and less
flexible than the standard 3d SC stick
the new analog input is surprisingly
responsive this addition will open the
door for developers to create better
camera controls you can still get these
features on an older 3ds or 3ds XL but
you need to purchase and attach the
bulky Circle Pad Pro add-on to do so yes
there will be games that are exclusive
to new 3d s in the future and it's
because of one new feature the faster
CPU with a slight uptick in performance
it should allow developers to push the
graphics hardware a little further
without fear of bottlenecking
performance having played Xenoblade
Chronicles on new 3ds it's not
surprising that the game needs the extra
oomph to run as well as it does however
you're more likely going to appreciate
the effect the faster CPU has on the
system as a whole the OS is snappier
than ever in games download and load
faster the 3ds OS no longer feels
sluggish are too demanding for the
hardware now it's just right intend has
made some great additions for new 3ds
but it's also changed a few things that
aren't necessarily for the better
up until now 3ds store data on SD cards
but new 3ds systems require microSD
cards instead which are much smaller by
comparison as a result existing 3d s
owners need to purchase a new card or
settle for the included four gigabyte
microSD card which is enough to get you
started but it's probably too small for
long-term storage needs in the past the
SD slot was readily available but now
you need to unscrew and dismantle the
underside of new 3dsxl is to access the
microSD slot granted this isn't
something you need to do maybe more than
once or twice during the lifespan your
system but when you do you'll encounter
stubborn screws and a panel that
practically refuses to detach it's
inconvenient to say the least but this
setup does allow for a great new feature
the ability to replace the system's
internal battery thankfully new 3d S
touts slightly improved
which will result in less wear and tear
over time as you deplete and recharge
the battery you can expect about 30
minutes of extra battery life compared
to older 3dsxl models intentos also
remix the layout of activity lights
ports and switches on the new 3ds start
and selector now discrete circular
buttons that live beneath the ABXY
buttons underneath the bottom screen the
home button sets a look the front of new
3ds XL is where you'll find the game
card slot a headphone port stylus and
the power button which have all been
repositioned in some way but something's
missing
the wireless radio switch it's a minor
inconvenience but you now need to press
the home button and access the quick
settings menu to turn the wireless
communications on or off of course
there's a lot of buzz in the nintendo
world about amiibo at the moment
Nintendo's NFC enabled figures are not
just cute but also functional allowing
you to carry your personal game data
from one device to another unlike past
3ds models new 3d s's have a built-in
NFC radio amiibo support for 3ds games
is basically non-existent at launch but
expect that to change quickly
Nintendo's promised an external amiibo
reading add-on for existing 3ds hardware
but new 3ds owners will be ready for
amiibo right out of the box there's much
to love about the new 3ds but Nintendo's
made one decision that will prove to be
an inconvenience for first-time 3ds
owners it's decided not to include a
charger in the box if you like me then
planning 3ds for years the overall
difference when you pick up a new 3ds XL
is immediately apparent after week with
a new system I just can't imagine going
back the 3d is too good and it's great
to see the OS get a speed boost anyone
who's picking up a 3ds for the first
time should skip the other options and
go right for the new 3ds XL because
picking up any other version is
essentially setting yourself up for
disappointment down the road once
exclusive games start to roll out the
existing 3ds owners should also consider
an upgrade if not now perhaps when
they're motivated by a certain game that
said if you spend a lot of time with
your 3ds and want a better experience
you won't be disappointed if you rush
out on a February 13th to pick up the
best handheld Nintendo's ever made